everybody okay so everyone's incredibly
thoughtful response about recommending
nominating and shining a light on local
and small businesses
we are curating everything we've got it
state by state we're gonna um
keep curating it we are with all of the
gifts
from the small business gift guide from
the drewberry moore show never in my
wildest dreams did i imagine that 80 000
people would submit businesses that they
loved
and we've built a business gift guide a
small business gift guide and it's going
to carry on
into 2021 i feel like i'm discovering
so many cool places that i totally want
to get people stuff from
colonel's nashville and hub coffee
roasters in
reno this is in a wet west virginia
paul's specialties uh urban farming
foodie flavor this is from hong's
dumpling
sweet cranberry sauce oh and hot chili
oil
we got some really beautiful masks made
from diop
we're gonna put boxes together for
everybody
and send it out and in each and every
box we are going to put the
little book of small businesses gift
guide
and then there's a note on the back that
says this gift is from our small
business gift guide in honor of
supporting our favorite small businesses
across the country we are thrilled to
share this special gift with you
happy holidays